Democrats once again create a circus a
national disgrace a high-tech lynching
this time around Brett Cavanaugh's
confirmation hearings we will analyze
the uncredible allegations against him
then Anne Hathaway spouts delightfully
frivolous lies and nonsense a take a
lobbying group gala we will look at what
her platitudes say about our culture
then Alexandria Ocasio Cortez where is
expensive clothing because everybody is
equal but some people are more equal
than others we'll talk about that
finally on this day in history the
signing of our Constitution I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
so much to get to today and a lot of
conservatives and Republicans getting
things wrong because it's a day that
ends in Y before we talk about all of
that I need to bring you into my boudoir
and I need to invite you to look at my
lingerie ooh la la whoo welcome hey baby
I'm talking about pair of thieves our
new sponsor and boy is pair of thieves
good so a pair of thieves points out
that on average men keep their underwear
for seven long years and for me I keep
them longer I'm a conservative I don't
want to give you too much information
I've got underwear probably from middle
school certainly high school boxers you
know and I don't know it's because I'm
frugal I'm a fiscal conservative I'm a
traditionalist anyway no more of that
because pair of thieves makes the most
comfortable underwear I have ever worn
hands down just get that image in your
head folks me lying down on a couch
smoking jacket on pair of thieves boxer
briefs lying there they have their
proprietary moisture wicking fabric
keeps you cool and fresh it's like air
conditioning for every inch of your body
it's really really good one of the guys
who started pair of thieves says all his
wife ever wants to see him in is a pair
of their super fit briefs his wife is
Jessica Alba that is no joke these are
the preferred boxer briefs of Jessica
Alba try them out for a limited time
this month only our listeners get 20%
off their first order pair of thieves
calm slash Noel's ko wles get 20% off
when you go to pair of thieves dot-com /
Noel's ko wles this month only get those
super fit briefs but they are real good
pair of thieves calm / knowles now that
you have that image in your head we are
not gonna stop talking about sex all day
now that it's in there it's all anybody
wants to talk about it so Lee Anne
Hathaway wants to talk about so all the
gutter Democrats want to talk about is
sex sex sex so I I'm sorry I'm getting
breaking I'm just one second getting
breaking news right now yes we are
hearing reports that Brett Kavanaugh is
a secret super Nazi we're hearing
reports they seem credible they're
credible reports because somebody said
it so it's got to be credible because
someone said it he is a super-secret
Nazi he's unfit for the Supreme Court
that's it I guess we're going to change
our show today it was all about
would be very good on the Supreme Court
but he's a super-secret Nazi because
there's a credible allegation because
it's credible because someone said it's
credible
so it's credible it's credible it's not
credible
none of these are credible so they're
saying that Brett Kavanaugh this is the
allegation I'm sure you've seen this
everywhere but it's probably been all
insinuation Zand what did he do this or
that they're trying to make it out like
he raped a woman or something the
allegation is that 35 years ago when
Brett Kavanaugh was 17 and was drunk at
a party he groped another teenage girl
who was also drunk and then he was like
you know kind of on top of her on a bed
and then she got away and then and
that's it that's the allegation that's
the whole thing
[ __ ] they don't mention where the party
was when when really the party was what
the circumstances were the story's
changing so now the Democrats are using
this 11th hour allegation to try to stop
the Cavanaugh hearing these allegations
are not credible period punto basta
no more fini they're not credible that
you hear why are they not credible
because of all the context surrounding
them they first of all because they came
up at the 11th hour so not during the
hearings not when Bret Kevin I could
have answered for himself now when we
could have actually investigated this
right before the vote these come up the
allegations were brought to Dianne
Feinstein she sat on them why did she
sit on them one because she probably
didn't believe them too because she knew
they could be discredited three because
she wanted to spring this at the last
second for Democrats to try to undo a
nomination which is certainly going to
go through it certainly should go
through so they do that why else are the
allegations not credible because they
were made for the first time publicly
like five minutes ago they they're about
an event that happened ostensibly 35
years ago and the first time they were
ever mentioned publicly in the public
space against a public figure who's been
a public figure for a long time was
about five minutes ago right at the very
end when they were about to confirm him
for the Supreme Court so why else are
these allegations not credible well some
other evidence that these might not be
is that the woman who made them is a
long time left-wing activist Democrat
activist donates to Democrat causes
volunteers her time puts her name on
petitions to support the Democrat Party
is an activist against the Trump
administration okay now none of that
proves that this didn't happen
I'm not saying with 100% certainty this
didn't happen I'm not saying with 100%
certainty that Brett Kavanaugh isn't a
super secret Nazi or that Dianne
Feinstein is into super secret Nazi I
don't you know you can't I can't prove a
negative I can't prove something that
allegedly happened 35 years ago which is
unverifiable and unfalsifiable but these
are not credible allegations the woman
who's making these allegations is
christine Blasi ford the first time she
had mentioned this at all period was in
2012 so six years ago and she mentioned
it to her psychiatrist or psychologist
or whatever and the therapist that she
was talking to took down the notes and
her story has radically changed since
that time so at the time she said that
there were four men who were in the room
when she was assaulted allegedly
assaulted now that's gone down to two
men who were in the room allegedly when
she was assaulted which is Brett
Kavanaugh and Mark judge who's a
conservative writer okay that's a pretty
big discrepancy that's the there were
100% more people when she recalled this
in 2012 but why did it take so long why
did it take so long for to mention it to
anybody she didn't mention it to any
friends at the time she didn't mention
it to any friends in 2006 when Brett
Kavanaugh became a judge she didn't
mention it until 2012 until six years
after that and until six years ago to
mention anything about this and at that
time she didn't name Brett Kavanaugh if
she really thought that there was a
would-be rapists sitting on the federal
courts don't you think she would have
named him in 2012 you would think so now
you might say why would she lie
why would someone bring up a false
accusation I don't know I couldn't tell
you and I'm not saying she's lying but I
do know that people make false
accusations all the time how many of
these alleged cases of rape on campus
have been proven to be hoaxes it's all
the way since the Duke Lacrosse case all
the way up through recent years a number
of them
do people lie I don't know I couldn't
tell you ask them we also know that she
brought this up in a session of marriage
counseling so I'm not not to denigrate
anybody who has mental health issues who
has psychiatric issues but she she is in
a mental health counseling she is
discussing this with her therapist and
we have to remember that memory is very
very unreliable I'm not saying this
woman is lying I don't know if she's
lying or not but it it is perfectly
plausible that she is remembering
something that did not happen
or did not happen the way that she
thinks it happened
memories change all the time they change
a pretty short order by the way they
change between you know over the course
of a few weeks or over the course of a
few months certainly over the course of
several decades there's an irony here
too though by the way because even if
these it let's let's say that all of the
allegations are true I don't think
they're true I don't think there's any
evidence that they're true but let's say
that they were the same people now who
are saying that we need to tar and
feather Brett Kavanaugh or the very same
people who were always pushing for
lenient punishments against teenagers
who there there's a movement now on the
left to create another sort of juvenile
court for people who were 20 21 years
old because they say oh those poor kids
their brains haven't developed yet they
can't be held responsible for crimes
that they've committed teenagers can't
be held responsible for crimes they've
committed they should be processed
separately it shouldn't be healthy so
all of those people the ones crying for
criminal justice reform even for adults
they're the ones who are now saying
Brett Kavanaugh allegedly groped a girl
when he was 17 so now his life has to be
over it's absurd but let's say that it
were true and let's say that this woman
is being earnest this really happened to
her it really had some effect on her
life even though she didn't mention it
for 30 years let's say all of that is
true she would be making allegations
worthy of belief if she had made them at
any other time but she didn't and you
don't get to do that you don't get to do
that you don't get to derail a guy who
has an unimpeachable career who has no
similar allegations made against him
ever at any point you don't get to
derail his career at the very last
moment just
cuz just because you said so you don't
get to if all of this happened and you
you have that right to go out there and
nail him you forfeited that right when
you didn't do it earlier when you didn't
do it in 2006 when he became a judge
when you didn't do it when he was
circulated as a potential Supreme Court
pet when you didn't do it until the very
last second you lose that credibility
and the Democrats obviously have no
credibility here if they really believed
that this were an issue that would have
brought it up when they first heard
about it they didn't they sent it over
to the FBI to investigate the FBI
dismissed it they wouldn't look into it
they said it was not worthy of
investigating so what we have now is
another high-tech lynching they did this
to Clarence Thomas in the early 90s here
is Joe Biden actually was chairing that
committee here is what they did to to
Clarence Thomas when he was up for the
nomination
they said that he sexually harassed his
colleague even though the colleague had
followed him from job to job she said it
was some awful example of sexual
harassment and here is how Clarence
Thomas put an end to the argument
committee will please come to order
Jerry you like this senator I would like
to start by saying unequivocally
uncatted Oracle II that I deny each and
every single allegation against me today
this is a case in which this sleaze this
dirt was searched for by staffers of
members of this committee was then
leaked to the media and this committee
and this body validated it and displayed
it at primetime over our entire nation
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace and from my standpoint as a
black American as far as I'm concerned
it is a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks who in any way deign to think for
themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the u.s. US Senate rather than hung from
a tree very powerful stuff from Clarence
Thomas guess what happened after that by
the way they voted for him and it
confirmed him it's great to is you have
Joe Biden just the least genuine person
in America the ly sincere human being in
America he's their presiding over the
hearings you mm-hmm and then the minute
that Clarence Thomas says from my view
this is a this is a high-tech lynching
you just see Biden's head go down he's
like Oh get me out of here duck and
cover
can I leave so the the reason that this
worked so well one is very powerful
stuff the allegations against Justice
Thomas were frivolous and one of the
reasons this worked is because Thomas
was able to turn the identity politics
of the left against them so he turned
their own argument against them Brett
Kavanaugh doesn't have the ability to do
that I say this is a high-tech lynching
for privileged white men who went to
Georgetown Prep not gonna land not gonna
play so we don't know how he's going to
answer this already all the usual
suspects are saying we can't vote for
him we need to hear more Jeff Flake
who's on the Judiciary Committee said oh
I don't think I can vote for him mm-hmm
I'm gonna go donate to Democrats in
Alabama mmm mmm Jeff Flake just horrific
what breaking news once again Jeff Flake
proves these are the worst so what is
going to happen we don't know it seems
that he'll still get through these
allegations are so absurd you own if you
wrote a satire of this you couldn't
write a more frivolous way of undoing
the Cavanaugh nomination then 35 years
ago when he was a teenager he groped me
and he says no I didn't and they said
well there's no proof at all because I
only brought it up three seconds ago but
please don't become a judge that's
that's their argument it's not I hope
it's not going to work
but this does bring up another point
which is I cannot wait for the Democrats
next judge nomination
I can't wait oh is that going to be good
because they keep doing it to us they
keep digging up this sleaze in the dirt
and I can't wait for their next one
because I think I'm not out of anger not
out of my temper but I think the
Democrats need to learn a lesson and I
feel real sorry for whoever that next
judicial nominee is from Democrats I
feel real sorry because it's gonna get
real real ugly before we get to why that
is the case why it is it would be very
wrong to consider these allegations
credible let me invite you into my
bedroom what did I tell you I told you
there's gonna be a lot of boudoir talk
today because I've got to tell you about
purple mattress oh how I love purple
mattress how did you sleep last night
did you spend the night tossing and
turning not me I sleep like a baby why
is that it all changed after purple
mattress purple is categorically
different from other mattresses you're
thinking oh the memory foam oh the
springs oh this is totally different
purple mattress is designed by rocket
scientists it uses a brand-new material
it is not like the memory foam or the
box spring or whatever that you are used
to it's both firm and soft at the same
time it keeps everything supported while
still feeling very comfortable and it's
breathable you know i'm a sicilian
descent so i sweat in the
air-conditioning and but it keeps it
very very cool it's really really good
you are going to love purple you will
end up feeling like you've got zero
gravity it works for any sleeping
position you can try it for 100 nights
risk-free if you're not fully satisfied
return the mattress for a full refund
it's backed up by 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free and home set
up and old mattress removal can't ask
for anything more
you are gonna love purple get this
mattress I'm telling you get it right
now because my listeners will get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress say that 10 times fast purple
pillow purchase purple that is in
addition to the great free gifts that
they're offering site-wide it's really
really good this is a brand new
technology go to purple com use the
promo code Kofi facio vfae feo check out
purple comm promo code cough fac o VF e
fe the only way to get the free pillow
is to use my promo code cough fa co v fe
f e it is it is the mattress
get it right don't get any other
mattress get this mattress purple
dot-com promo code Kofi Fei
so when we look at these allegations
these eleventh-hour allegations I think
look nobody wants to tell an accuser
that they're not going to believe her
even though you know sometimes people
make false accusations I'm not saying
that's what this woman is doing people
feel all we want to say is oh well who
knows we have to delay we have to hear
this out we don't have to hear this out
we don't if we were going to hear this
out we should have heard this out two
months ago we do not we are we are under
no obligation to hear this out
but the the timing all of the context
around this makes it stink to high
heaven
as a political dirty trick it is bad for
our politics for us to take this
seriously to even consider taking this
seriously people if people have genuine
grievances if people have genuinely been
hurt or attacked or whatever that should
be aired we should investigate all of
that it is so awful for our politics to
just smear good people smear them it
discourages good people from going into
public service
first of all everybody is tarnished
everyone's done bad things you know it
Eve but even if you haven't done bad
things even if you've got as
unimpeachable record as judge Cavanaugh
what this now tells you is you're gonna
get smeared either way they're gonna
they're gonna go into your distant
distant past and either find something
exaggerate something or make something
up whole cloth imagine how squeaky-clean
you've got to be for the best shot for
Democrats is to go back to when you were
seventeen and either make something up
or even find something that has a kernel
of truth to it which I don't think this
does imagine that it discourages good
people out of politics it's so below or
caliber as a country and below our
politics we should ignore it we should
totally ignore it and the next time
someone ever wants to make an allegation
like this again against another judicial
nominee do it do it early do it when
there's time for people to defend
themselves when there's time to
investigate if you're not going to do
that if you're not going to leave time
to investigate if you're not going to
leave time for people to have to be
treated fairly
then the accusation is not worthy of
even investigating so moving on speaking
of other crazy things crazy ideology
that leads to political hysteria
Saturday
Anne Hathaway was speaking at the Human
Rights Campaign gala the Human Rights
Campaign is a gay lobbying organization
they're the one with the equal sign and
she was speaking at their gala and she I
think this was the most incoherent
oration I've ever heard but there are a
lot of interesting kernels in here for
what our culture and our politics means
right now
take it away Ann the exception of being
a cisgender male everything about how I
was born has put me at the current
center of a damaging and widely accepted
myth that myth is that gayness orbits
around straightness transgender orbits
around cisgender and that all races
orbit around whiteness so she's talking
about a myth
she's talking about this this awful
foundational myth and then she goes on
to create her own myth and and what
she's saying is that gayness orbits
around straightness what does that mean
what does that picture really mean I
think what she's actually saying is that
the gayness is a little bit abnormal and
straightness is the normal statistically
speaking biologically speaking most
people are straight or our reproductive
systems seem to be designed for a man
and a woman to you know head over to a
purple mattress and do whatever they're
going to do and that other other more
creative sexualities or a little
abnormal certainly that's the case but
she's saying that isn't the case it's
all exactly the same it's all exactly
equally normal how about transgenderism
she's saying we have this crazy idea
that if you're a man that you should
think that you're a man instead of
thinking me or a woman that it's
abnormal if you're a man to think that
you're a woman of course that's abnormal
of course that's ignore and then she
says that we have this pernicious belief
that of other races orbit around
whiteness I don't really know what that
means
I suppose being of a different race in a
country where they're founded on a race
then I guess that would make sense you
know if you're if you're a Kenyan guy
who's living in Norway that might be a
little abnormal because
Norway isn't full of Kenyans it's full
of Norwegians so if you're a Kenyan
there you're you're not the common type
of person okay fine fair enough
that isn't the case in America though
which has every sort of color every sort
of race all sorts of people that doesn't
seem like there's one normal person in
America certainly not Anne Hathway she
is definitely not a normal person in
America so she's talking about this myth
but did you see even at the top she said
I but you know I have all of this
privilege maiya colpa Mia culpa Mia
culpa
at least I'm not a man who thinks he's a
man but I'm still bad I'm bad then she
she goes on that is with us from birth
and it is a myth that keeps money and
power in the hands of the few instead of
being invested in the lives of the free
so she's getting raucous applause she
sounds like she's giving a real speech
she said it this this myth this
pernicious lie that were founded on
keeps money in the hands of the few and
out of the hands of the free so she's
saying there's a dichotomy between the
few and the free but her entire speech
is talking about how the majority of
people are actually enslaved to these
privileged people so I don't see how are
they free
I thought previously you were just
saying that it's those awful privileged
white straight people who think they're
their own biological sex those are the
free ones and everyone else isn't free
so she's using language really really
loosely here and she's saying that to
distill it in just normal clear language
she's saying that straight people make
more money than gay people but that
isn't true that just simply isn't true
there was a study that came out from the
National Health Interview Survey
it came out of these economists at
Vanderbilt University showed that gay
men actually earned 10% more than
straight men
that's just earnings to say nothing of
wealth so even on that point that it
keeps money out of the hands of this and
that and this and that that isn't true
actually if you're gay you that gives
you a certain privilege that allows you
to earn more money according to these
surveys and according to the premises of
this ideology but it doesn't matter
because the ideology of the human rights
campaign of the equal sign of Hollywood
of the popular culture that is the lie
she goes on
equality authentic equality doesn't
prioritize sexual orientation it doesn't
put anyone gender or race at the center
it doesn't erase our identities either
what it does do is centralize love and
when love is fully centralized every
door opens for everybody you know man
when you just you just got a really
centralized it man and then the chakras
man you know what she has just said
contradicts her first premise she has
said that what what this wonderful
movement is going to do is centralize
love but in the first premise she said
the the problem that we have is that we
have love being centralized and then
other sorts of love orbiting around it
whereas you said well this is central
and then other things were orbiting
around it so the centralization of love
seems to be the problem actually what an
should be arguing for in her speech is
the decentralization of love right that
it's not just straight love that matters
it's not just trans love or cisgender
love whatever crazy language she's gonna
make up it should be arguing for
decentralization but this argument that
she's making doesn't make a whole lot of
sense it she's just if that love wins
hashtag love wins its that Anthony
Kennedy and obergefell saying we have a
right to intimacy we have a right to
love you say that sounds that has the
sound of poetry to it but what does it
really mean what she's just said means
nothing it contradicts the very
arguments she's been making but then if
you were confused by her abstractions
don't worry she explains why you were
confused by her abstractions now
I know I'm speaking in abstractions and
that there is privilege embedded in my
ability to do so they're their
abstraction privilege we now have
abstraction press a privilege apparently
that Anne Hathaway does not possess but
a because she's not doing abstraction
very well but I love this point she's
talking about abstraction privilege
there really is abstraction privilege
that's true it's called consciousness
it's called being a human that is our
privilege I agree we have a privilege
over the dogs and the cows and the
kittens and the Apes we do we have the
ability for abstract thinking we have
the ability for a recursive language we
have the ability to be conscious and
think and reflect upon our own
circumstances we have the ability to
match intellect and will that is a
privilege but that is not a privilege
only for straight people or only for
white people or only for people who
think that they are the biological sex
that they are or that isn't that's what
we have as humans that is the essential
Equality of humans that is why we are
all children of God because we are all
endowed by our Creator with that
consciousness with that ability to know
ourselves to know our world and to know
our Creator a wonderful point that she
is totally undercutting by the argument
that she thinks she is making and then
she turns that self flagellation up to
eleven here we go in this community and
rejects the myth of their own
unworthiness and more importantly the
myth that they need others to be worth
less in order for them to be worth more
the walls built in fear will crumble
they will disintegrate the old world
will shatter and the pieces that no
longer serve will melt a new world will
emerge forge from this community from
there sighs from your seismic imperative
message that love is love
I need a lot more if I'm gonna
understand that one I'm gonna need a lot
more Kofi Fae in the old burner if I'm
gonna get that she ends with love is
love because that is the truism and the
platitude that this is all based on love
is love but then in that first part she
constructs an abominable world and it's
not that she's first making is she's the
first to make this argument people have
made this argument before it goes back a
long long time she talks about how we
need to reject the fact that we're not
worthy that we're imperfect you hear
this all the time I heard this from my
Panda Express
a fortune cookie the other day it said
you were perfect the way that you are
but you're not you're not perfect the
way that you are I don't say that to be
mean I say that actually as a moment of
compassion because if you think that
you're perfect the way that you are
you're good you're quickly going to find
out that you're not and you'll be left
with despair it is a much more hopeful
and truthful understanding of the world
that we are not perfect the way that we
are we all know this even Brett
Kavanaugh who's pretty unimpeachable I'm
sure he tells a lie every now and again
or he you know cut somebody off in
traffic or something I don't know we're
all we're all imperfect we're all fallen
people and what this movement is saying
what Anne Hathaway is saying what the
Human Rights Campaign is saying with the
equal sign and with the with the
promotion of Pride Week is that we
should be proud of ourselves we
shouldn't be aware of our own
unworthiness
she also says this is kind of ironic she
says we shouldn't have to put other
people down to build ourselves up she
just spent a whole speech putting down
white people straight people people who
think that they are the biological sex
that they are she's putting down people
throughout the whole thing and spouting
off a bunch of lies and she says but we
shouldn't do that
this is Democrats do this all the time
they're doing it in the Cavanaugh
hearings they're doing it certainly in
the Trump administration we'll get to
that in a second and then she says when
she's speaking at her most theological
her most apocalyptic she says we're
going to shatter this world we're going
to create a new world we're not going to
accept things the way that they are we
are going to create a whole new world
and you hear Democrats have been saying
this for 50 years
they have been quoting George Bernard
Shaw's play back to Methuselah you heard
the Kennedys say this all of the
Kennedys I think in various speeches
said some people look at the world and
ask why some people look at things that
are and ask why I look at things that
never were and ask why not
I dream of things that never were and
ask why not and they're quoting this as
though this were some great wonderful
speech it's not they are quoting George
Bernard Shaw's back to Methuselah but
specifically they are quoting the
serpent in the garden tempting Eve the
impact Methuselah that is what that line
does say some people look at things in
our and ask why I dream of things that
never were and ask why not that is the
language of Satan because reality is a
beautiful thing life is a comedy it's
the greatest story ever told it's a
grand comedy it's a as horace walpole
says life is a comedy to the man who
thinks and a tragedy to the person who
feels some people want to get out of the
world of reality they're afraid of it
they run away from reality so they
drugged themselves up or they drink too
much or they lose themselves into
fantasies and fairy tales but reality is
a beautiful thing you should confront
reality and not try to destroy the world
and create a new world on top of it that
is not not a strategy for success but
the left abuses language in this way all
the time
it sounds so compassionate as she said
love is love love is love this is the
same thing with these Cavanagh hearings
so I think we're all tempted because
we're emotionally manipulated by certain
people and certain political programs to
feel us to lean into this love is love
is love love is love but love that is
not grounded in truth that is not
grounded in reality that actually is
Anne Hathaway says is opposed to reality
that isn't love that sentimentality and
sentimentality is an awful thing
sentimentality can be used and abused
its saccharine its sick it will leave
you unsatisfied and it can be twisted
for very bad things very unreal things
because it's opposed to the very nature
of reality the mainstream media have
been twisting language on and on again
our pals at the Media Research Center
have just analyzed a study of this they
have found the words that the mainstream
media had been used
most frequently to describe President
Trump what do you think handsome
competent courageous is that were there
and you know not quite not quite the
words that the mainstream media been
using to describe from most often are
angry furious fuming outraged venting
infuriated livid enraged and seething
those are the words that they're using
most frequently to refer to try their
proper using it more than he or the or
him you know Donald they they're using
those adjectives to describe him and it
creates a picture in our mind of this
guy who's totally unbalanced who's
insane who's lost his mind
and yet when we see president from
speaking when we see his agenda in
action when we see how much he's
accomplished in a very short period of
time
it really butts up against that doesn't
it when you see that you think what is
it that doesn't seem like a guy who's
not in control of his emotions and
Hathaway might not be in control of her
emotions but Donald Trump certainly
seems like he is people who can't
control their passions don't accomplish
very much they can't because they're
always lost in a torrent of passion and
emotion Donald Trump's accomplished a
lot a lot on the economy a lot on
Foreign Affairs
obviously the judges I think he's got a
record number of judges through oh he's
been accomplishing so much he's
accomplished a lot in his life this is
not a guy who is led around aimlessly by
passion but the media wants to pretend
that he is and they're also trying to
create this image that he he can't he
can't control his own thinking that he's
a childish that he's immature John Kerry
former Secretary of State and the former
star of deputy dog was on Bill Maher
show last week here is how he described
Donald Trump he is he really is the rare
combination of a eight-year-old boy and
he's got the maturity of an
eight-year-old boy with the insecurities
of a teenage girl
[Applause]
now imagine if Donald Trump had said
that about John Kerry
what would the mainstream media if
Donald Trump came at me said look John
Kerry okay he's got the maturity of an
eight-year-old boy okay and he's he's
got the insecurities frankly of a
teenage girl okay if he had said that it
would be headline news what this is
awful he's defacing the office of
president blah blah blah
but because John Kerry sounds like
Thurston Howell the third and he goes on
Bill Maher sure he says well frankly son
here's my conundrum what was that John
mmmmm-hmmmm can someone pry open John
Kerry's locked jaw please rate your old
boy because he does it like that because
he wears the suit so nicely but it has
his tie all the way up to his neck then
people take him always so serious oh no
that's that's that's how respectful
responsible people behave
that's how mature states when we have
unlike Trump they're saying the same
thing they're saying exactly the same
thing and it's not just John Kerry
here's Joe Biden doing doing precisely
the same thing there are small
percentage of American people
virulent people some of them the dregs
of society dregs of society dregs of
soften people dregs of society he's
talking about Trump supporters and
actually at the Human Rights Campaign
the same thing that a in Hathaway was
speaking at he's talking about half of
the country's talking about Trump
supporters he's calling him the dregs of
society and yet when Donald Trump calls
a handful of hack journalists scum
then it's awful then it's an attack on
our country it's an attack on our
countrymen but Joe Biden former vice
president of the United States refers to
half the country's the dregs of society
that's okay it's applause he's wearing a
tuxedo look he's wearing a tux
he can't be immature and uncivil he's in
a tuxedo we've got a lot more even more
Democrats are doing this before we get
to it though before we get to celebrate
a Constitution day before we get to
talking about Hillary before we get to
talk about Alexandria occasionally
cortex I stole that from Steve Hayward I
can't take credit for that Alexandria
occasional cortex before we talk about
all of that I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube if you are on
Facebook and YouTube go to daily wire
come on
you're there thank you very much you
help keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup you keep me sleeping
soundly on my purple mattress all snug
as a bug with my pair of thieves boxers
on you do a lot for me basically is what
I'm saying if you haven't subscribed
it's ten bucks a month 100 dollars for
an annual membership you get me you get
the indra clave ensure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag that's coming up on Thursday
you get to ask questions in the
conversation much more importantly you
get the leftists here's tumblr and we've
been focusing a lot on Washington
leftist ears recently and look there are
some great vintages of leftist ears that
come out of Washington but now we've got
that Ann Holloway and Hathaway Hollywood
vintage and those are those are tasty
those you know I do think that the
ground is much more fertile out here in
Hollywood the sun is shining more and it
just produces more delicious leftist
yours so go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back so that's the insulting
reckless bitter immature language of
statesmen former Secretary of State
former senators former vice president
it's also true in the left wings pundit
class even The Washington Post the these
left-hand pundits who go on TV here's
Jennifer Rubin talking about the
president Donald Trump has killed it
those people twice once through neglect
and oversight and secondly disgracing
that they died at all and that's what
death denial that's what Holocaust
denial that's what all these denial
syndromes are all about is killing the
person twice so Donald Trump is a
murderer he's a Nazi yeah he's a
Holocaust denier and he's killed people
twice because there was a hurricane
that's Jennifer Rubin a left-wing
analyst with the Washington Post who I
think she pretends to be a Republican
still but obviously she's a very
left-wing partisan and has been for a
long time because there was a hurricane
because Donald Trump controls the
weather I guess he's got even more power
than I think he thought he had because
he controls the weather he's a Nazi
Holocaust denying double murderer and I
don't mean double murder like he killed
two people I mean double murderer that
he killed the same person twice that's
what he did according to the left but
but Trump's using crazy language isn't a
he's being so uncivil oh this is bad oh
we we Republicans should really take
stock of ourselves oh oh no I how could
we may occult but me give me a break
give me a break when they talk about
incivility
just laugh just laugh in their face when
they talk about Brett Kavanaugh is like
a super-secret Nazi rapist murderer just
laugh at them just laugh they have no
credibility whatsoever it is not worth
even acknowledging their stupid
hysterical cries they're behaving like
little children they should be treated
like little children Hillary Clinton
today heads this piece in from the
Atlantic because she wrote a new chapter
for her book what happened I think she's
gonna write a new chapter every month
it's them I don't know is the
macedonians before now it's the
Ghanaians and now it's the Nigerians now
okay whatever so she wrote this piece in
the Atlantic on our constitutional
crisis because our Democrat
institutions our democracy is being
undermined it's under attack that's what
she's a legend she's alleging this as
the woman who is undermining her
democracy as the woman who is
undermining our democratic election or
duly elected president she's saying it's
under a tag it's under a tech she's okay
it's okay Shh
she's my third cousin once removed as
you all know it's hush it's okay it's
all right
you lost if Mitt Romney had done this in
2012 he would be excoriated people
aren't excoriating you because they
haven't you know wrapped her up in a
straitjacket and hauled her out of those
woods in Chappaqua yet she's behaving
like a crazy person she's not to be
taken seriously they are not to be taken
seriously now this doesn't mean that we
should delve to their level maybe their
next judge candidate you know maybe we
maybe we give them a little taste of
their own medicine but I don't think
generally we should delve to their level
it does mean though that we should stop
flogging ourselves when a Republican
uses nasty language when Donald Trump
sends out a mean tweet and Republicans
there are some Republicans and some
conservatives who spend more time
shrieking about Donald Trump's tweets
than they ever would talking about Joe
Biden or John Kerry from Jennifer Rubin
or Hillary Clinton because they feel oh
I don't want to be seen as one of those
people it's okay
it's all right politics is ugly Otto von
Bismarck I think said that it's much
better to eat the sausage without seeing
how it's made you know politics is an
ugly business it's particularly ugly at
this moment it's all right doesn't mean
we shouldn't fight back we should fight
back because there are actual stakes
here there was actual freedom there's
actual American Liberty there was actual
American Western civilization at stake
we should fight hard to protect it a lot
of hypocrisy on this front a lot of
hypocrisy from the left I do want to
speak briefly before we have to go about
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez she did this
interview in Interview magazine creative
creative title and the in the interview
she was wearing a $3,500 outfit so she
was wearing a blazer that was almost
$2,000 she was wearing pants that were
almost $1000 she was 600 other shoes
okay people are attacking her because
she's a socialist self-proclaimed
socialist wearing
thousands of dollars of clothing now
some are saying it's not fair they
always go after women women wear
expensive clothing lay off no it's not
fair when they go after Republican women
it is fair when they go after socialists
not even all Democrats it's not even
fair when they go after all Democrats
but it is totally fair game when they go
after socialists this woman is saying we
need to soak the rich take all of their
money wealth is bad choice is bad Bernie
Sanders her dear pal when he was running
in 2016 one of his major talking points
is that we have too many choices of
deodorant there's no joke that when you
go to the drugstore you see too many
choices of deodorant we need we don't
need all that deodorant we only need one
or two
we need to centralize it and stop people
from having all these nice things then
she wears $3,000 worth of clothing 3,500
dollars worth of clothing that is
hypocrisy I'm not out there saying that
we all need to be exactly materially
equal exactly financially equal she is
and she's giving that old George Orwell
animal farm line we're all equal but
some of us are more equal than others
that's the Alexandria Ocasio cortes line
and that's exactly what's going to
happen if her preferred system of
government is instituted if socialism is
instituted there will be a concentration
of wealth and power and privilege among
the chrony class and she will be right
there it's totally fair it is an issue
of hypocrisy this also brings us to
Chelsea Clinton I want to get to before
we go
Chelsea Clinton over the weekend you
know she's a big abortion proponent
she's been talking about how great roe v
wade is how we should have legal
abortion and why cuz she's a Democrat
she's a political animal I mean she was
created in in a environment of politics
she's been in politics her whole life
then she went a little too far here's
what she said about roe v wade is a
deeply religious person it's also
unchristian so she's saying she's a she
goes on and I'm in the interview but
that's all you need to hear she says as
a deeply religious person it would be
unchristian to outlaw abortion there are
plenty of people who are Christian who
support abortion in spite of their faith
I think almost half of American
Catholics support abortion even other
faiths clearly says that abortion is
gravely immoral and intrinsically evil
okay some people do that some people
have a complicated view of theology
they're on a spiritual journey they
haven't gotten there yet that's fine
look I went from atheist to Catholic to
a you know Christian revert in an over a
number of years and it doesn't happen
all at once it kind of okay that's fine
but to pretend that your support for
killing little babies comes from your
Christian faith is outrageous that is
awful and that is really really a
terrible thing she should be called out
for it Matt Walsh called her out for it
and I think she responded to him you
know it is that is a step too far you
know it's it's one thing too we see this
a lot in the breakdown of the church we
see this a lot in the breakdown of
American politics it's one thing to say
I understand that there is a moral order
and I'm violating it and I'm doing it
because I'm a weak and broken person but
I still acknowledge that there's a moral
order that's one thing it's a totally
different thing to say there's no moral
order good is bad up is down war is
peace murder is great
that's a total that is much more
pernicious even if you're doing the
exact same thing to deny the very
essence of an order of a political or of
a moral order that is much much worse
it's much more dangerous
that's the territory that the left is
moving into when her mother ran for
president in 2008 she said abortion
should be safe legal and rare now
Chelsea Clinton is saying abortion is a
great thing and it's very Christian that
is a huge shift and this is where heresy
creeps in in religion and this is where
our constitutional order is seriously
undermined and broken down when people
undercut the very doctrines the very
philosophical premises and institutions
that undergo a country this brings us in
the last few minutes to Constitution Day
on this day in history in 1787 our
wonderful Constitution was signed it's a
great thing you can see I'm wearing my
time my Constitution day time so we
don't need to give a lecture on the
Constitution because if you're watching
or listening to this show you probably
know a lot about the Constitution
unfortunately most people in America
don't know very much about the
Constitution there was a poll out from
the Annenberg Public Policy Center out
of the University of Pennsylvania which
shows from that of all Americans 37
percent cannot name a single right
protected by the First Amendment First
Amendment protects multiple rights free
speech free assembly no establishment of
religion right
they can't name what three-quarters of
Americans cannot name all three branches
of our government the executive the
legislature and the judiciary
one-third of Americans can't name any
branch of our government just pretty
crazy because all we talk about now is
the president it can't even name one of
them this is a scary thing because our
Constitution is a wonderful document
it's a great piece of paper
it sets up a terrific government from
the greatest nation in them certainly in
the modern era probably in the history
of the world but if you don't know it if
you don't know about your Constitution
if you don't know about your government
if you don't know about the institutions
created and described by the
Constitution it's not going to exist
very long freedom isn't passed in the
bloodstream it's only one generation
away from extinction as Ronald Reagan
used to say and we're talking now
coincidentally on constitution day about
a new Supreme Court justice who's going
to go to the court and interpret the
Constitution
hopefully defend the Constitution
against other judges who want to
undermine the Constitution and now there
are these crazy allegations that he's a
monster he's a thirty five years ago he
groped a girl or something okay
the allegations he do are not credible
but even if they were we also have to
remember that men are not angels and
this was what Alexander Hamilton
described about our Constitution he said
quote if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary in framing a government which
is to be administered by men over men
the great difficulty lies in this you
must first enable the government to
control the governed and in the next
place oblige it to control itself men
are not angels
we're not governed by angels there are
bad guys who govern us I think Brett
Kavanaugh is probably on the very good
end of men who govern us some other
people might have a little
body or past you know I'm not calling
out our president at the moment but he's
got a little more of a checkered
personal history than someone like judge
Cavanaugh
okay the guard rares rails hold the the
government was set up because we're not
a nation of men where our nation doesn't
rise and fall depending on the men who
are running in or we're a nation of laws
but we need to understand those laws we
have to understand our own system of
government John Adams said that the
Constitution is built for a moral and
religious people and it's unfit to
govern anybody else we're seeing a huge
decline in religiosity among people
we're seeing a huge decline in knowledge
of our country and when that happens
well forget about the people governing
us think about the people who are being
governed when that happen we don't know
our country and we don't know our
Constitution and we can't discipline
ourselves when we can't govern ourselves
no piece of paper is going to protect us
no piece of paper is going to help we
can have as many tea party rallies as we
want we can go either we say this is a
great document you should read might I
read it it won't matter because the
people have to understand their
government they have to be educated in
it they need to be citizens being a
citizen is not a passive activity you
know it's not just bread and circuses
and being entertained you have to
participate in your government if you're
gonna govern yourself and if you're
unwilling to participate unwilling to
educate yourself unwilling to discipline
yourself then someone is gonna run your
life for you that's the debate that
we're having right now I hope that we'll
be speaking on next year's Constitution
Day and things will be looking even
better but who knows it's up to us it's
up to us to decide what kind of country
we want to have okay that's our show
we ran late as usual I'll be back not
tomorrow we will not have a show
tomorrow we're gonna do a show on Friday
so I'll be back I'll see you on
Wednesday in the meantime I'm Michael
Mel's this is the Michael Nolt show I'll
see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you